les clayes-sous-bois sorte de la coupe
gambardella la tête haute les bleus se
sont inclinés contre caen terme d'un
match très offensif
pourtant ce 6e tour de la coupe de
france des moins de 19 ans avait très
bien débuté avec un but du milieu
offensif nicolas fadi en première
période
[Applaudissements]
au retour des vestiaires les clients
baisser de rythme encaissé trois buts en
sept minutes avant de réagir sur penalty
la fin de match est équilibré les deux
équipes trouvent le chemin des filets
score final 4 à 3 la victoire logique
pour eux
oui et non parce qu'en première mi temps
ils ont énormément d'occasions il rappe
ténors mais man des 0 à la mi temps les
a prévenus on l'a redit attention ils
ont eu énormément d'occasions ils n'ont
pas cadré en dynamitant ça pas pardonné
il est trop de relâchement dans le temps
faibles c'est là où on a pris le but
et voilà après on a vu on a repris le
contrôle du ballon on a remarqué mais
trop tard malgré la défaite plusieurs
joueurs se sont révélés pendant la
partie c'est le cas de thé au maréchal
surnommé le temps d'un après midi thé ou
neuer en référence au gardien champion
du monde allemand très bon regardez
aujourd'hui qui est très bon toujours
aujourd'hui je suis fier de lui parce
que ça faisait attrait depuis l'année
dernière que je l'avais en u17
j'attendais un très grand match de lui
un match 100% parce qu'il me fait
toujours des matches à 40% des parades
décisives qui ont enflammé le public du
stade beltramini plusieurs centaines de
supporters avaient fait le déplacement
pour voir la rencontre et encourager les
joueurs on est fiers représente le tout
sous bois on se connaît dans les cent
soixante quatre meilleures équipes de
france
en sachant qu'un à plus de 2000 voilà
même quand repartiront ils pourront dire
que les clayes-sous-bois voilà ça n'a
pas été un match facile
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle campagne en gambardella pour
les clayes-sous-bois il faudra se
reconcentrer dès le week-end prochain
sur le championnat
l'efsc les siens sont actuellement
deuxième de 2e division de district
[Musique]